[Music]
I would say
oh man it is him come on come on come on
what he's he yeah they finished it and
he's right bloody here
[Music]
[Music]
and initiate sequencing
[Music]
and hope memories are made of this what
is this fullest I'm sorry to be the one
to tell you this but you got yourself
killed
at rst we'd rebuild the most important
assets in the US military soldiers like
yourself you're the first who we
successfully managed to bring back but
improved enhanced with the technology in
veins you have an army inside you that
will not only make you stronger he will
heal you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
where you going I've got unfinished
business
oh that's not good all right shut him
down and initiate sequence
okay who is the next target for
elimination
these are made of they tell me do you
remember anything do I know you guys I
don't think so
I've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes ain't
and initiate sequence
control me
sure about that
is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
[Music]
that is absolutely fantastic
[Music]
and as I could just heard this is the
Clinton assembly people
her body can't do this forever
I was coming
what happened you're the first so sweet
successfully managed to bring back do
you sing you brought me back to life
bun-chucks a soldier at his corp he is
the military's favorite superhero the
technology in your veins so not only
make you stronger they'll repair you
instantly as a hero is made an
incredible sacrifice and he's been given
the second chance we develop super
soldiers like yourself improved enhanced
the call your blood shot yeah
the idea is to weaponize him you know
like a knight in shining armor except
they don't really wear any parma now do
you want an upgrade
make sure you catch my new movie plus
[Music]
[Music]